you guys and how did that affect your
play the rest of the game
i don't think it affected my play at all
i thought i played as hard as i can
today um
you know listen tom brady's a great
quarterback um
you know i never really saw that side of
tom brady to be honest um
but whatever no comment uh it's over
with i'm done with it
it's yeah it's it's i love tyron matthew
you can't say no comment is the final
two words of your answer you've already
commented on it but
uh it was it was a stunning moment for
me and let's get right into the fill in
the blank because that's the first
subject the tom brady tyron matthew
trash talk was what for you shireen
it was unexpected i thought mike there's
players out
there that i thought would do the trash
talking those probably aren't the two
that would be at the top of my list
trash talking
and i hope one of them ends up was was
miked up or somebody was close enough
who was miked up that we get to hear
that whole
shame change at some point because i
want to know how it started and what was
said and
i don't know right now and i don't know
if you have a better feel for it than i
do
of who actually started it it almost
looked like maybe tom brady started that
i don't know why but they both went at
it for
for a while and i was surprised that
that tyrant matthew was the one that got
flagged on that
well we talked about that earlier down
pft live it's not the guy who starts it
but the guy who finishes it who ends up
getting the flag and for me
for me that incident was the moment
the instant i saw that yellow glove with
the finger pointed at tom brady that was
the moment that i said holy crap the
bucks are gonna win this game now i
wasn't far out on a limb it was 21 to 6
or 20 to 6 at that moment but that to me
was a reflection
that the chiefs had been broken by the
buccaneers
that this isn't the team that you can
that you can
rest assured is going to find a way to
come back from any and all deficits it
wasn't 24
nothing down to the texans it wasn't 10
points down
to the 49ers with seven minutes left in
super bowl 54. there was always a
swagger to the chiefs even when they
were losing
no matter how badly they were losing
that moment to me
was they've lost their swagger they've
lost their edge tyrant matthew was
trying to will it back by getting in tom
brady's face regardless of who started
it
when i saw that that was when that
little that little voice says that's it
it's done you were right the buccaneers
are going to win the game but you were
wrong to think it may have been a
chief's win or a chief's blowout
the bucks are the ones that are going to
get the easy victory today
and i'm not prompting tom brady mike
that's the last thing
i want to do we know how much he has a
chip on his shoulder
even now and how much he's motivated by
other guys
talking to him and chip chirping at him
and all those sorts of things so
i i'm not inciting tom brady if i'm any
one of those cheese players
at all that's not what i want i remember
all too well the 2007 season when the
patriots were undefeated the steelers
went
up to play new england in december
anthony smith
former steelers safety guaranteed that
the steelers would win
tom brady picked on him all day long and
got in his
face i mean brady is capable of that now
i'm not aware of anything that tyron
matthews said
and maybe there was something that got
back to brady privately i don't know
now it's been leaked that brady
apologized to tyron matthew
for instigating that outburst i don't
know why that's not something brady
could come out and say on his own but uh
i guess the incident's over tom brady
has apologized even though tom brady
wasn't the one
who drew the flag there was another
taunting incident involving the
buccaneers and the chiefs this time the
flag went on the buccaneers
and this time the buccaneers player had
no apologies no qualms
and no regrets here's antoine winfield
jr
talking about the foul he received for
throwing up the deuces
at tyree kill who is well known for
throwing up the deuces at everyone he
runs away
it's from man i it's something i just
had to do um
when we played him earlier you know hill
went off
on us he backflipped in front of my face
gave me the peace sign so it was only
right that
i gave the peace sign right back to him
at this moment
it felt amazing to be able to do that
not even gonna lie
he's gonna get fined but he doesn't care
but you know tyree kill always gets away
with that
he runs away from guys and he throws up
the two fingers as he's running into the
end zone and he
look at that that is great and yeah he
look he was doing backflips he was doing
gymnastics routines the last time he was
in tampa
and these buccaneers players remembered
it so when it got to the moment where it
was done now
you know antoine winfield was smart
enough not to do it when the game
was still kind of in dispute he waited
until very late in the fourth quarter to
throw up the deuces
but you know he was waiting weeks for
the opportunity to give it back to
tyreek hill shereen
oh there's absolutely no question so i
got on last night i'm writing this post
right i had listened to winfield and so
i'm writing this post
so i went back and i watched the first
quarter of the week 12 game
and he did it was on the 75 yard
touchdown i believe was the one where he
threw up the deuces
and then on the next touchdown which was
like 34 yards or something like that he
stopped before the goal line and did the
back flip
and it was all up in winfield's face so
i thought it was deserved mike and i
chuckled that i thought it was pretty
funny i guess if you're a cheese fan or
a tyree kill fan it wasn't quite so
funny but
you know if you're a cheese fan you go
oh that's great ha ha
it's funny and then when tyree kill gets
it done to him it's not quite so funny
well
no that's not funny at all well you
can't have it one way it's either one
way or anything
it's got to be both ways so you know i i
thought it was well deserved i laughed
at it
and uh we'll see what happens from there
but
it is it will be interesting if he gets
fined for that because you're right
tyree kill did not get
fined he has gotten fined before for
throwing up the deuces but
the last time i could find was like 2018
that he got fined i went back and did a
search
so i don't think he's gotten fined for
doing that over the last couple years
the nfl's kind of stepped away from that
so i hope they don't find antoine
winfield for doing the same thing that
tyra killed didn't get fined for
by the way chiefs fans the appropriate
twitter handle to which you should
direct your comments is at
nfl shereen c-h-a-r-e-a-n
not at pro football talk you can have
fun with them for a while
instead of me but but yeah it was it was
fun it was a fun moment
and winfield wisely waited until it was
too late for the chiefs to do a damn
thing
about it uh one thing the chiefs didn't
do was target carlton davis who had been
torched last time around not targeting
carlton davis was what shireen
i thought it was a huge mistake on the
cheese part because
tyree kill did torch him in the first
quarter of that first game in week 12
and
had 203 yards in the first seven catches
203 yards and two touchdowns
against carlton davis in the first
quarter of that game
and part of it was they got pressure on
patrick mahomes
it was we talked about this a little bit
in the first segment but mike the 29
pressures for the most in super bowl
history he's running for his life and
had trouble getting enough time to get
the ball down the field to tyree kill
but
they absolutely should have found
carlton davis on the field wherever he
was
whoever he was against and targeted him
i think they would have much better
success
targeting carlton davis i mean one thing
that they got away from that worked so
well against the bills those little
short passes to tyree kill where he just
start
starts spinning guys around right making
grown men look like little kids
who can't who can't barely walk i mean
we saw none of that we saw none of it
and uh yeah i was stunned
that that they didn't continue to go
after a guy that had such a hard time
the last time around although
with with double coverage but you know
what it's tyree kill who cares about
double coverage
it's tyree kill it's patrick mahomes
triple coverage there's still a window
there into which the ball can be thrown
right here's devin white the buccaneers
linebacker and defensive captain talking
about the team being
underdogs for sunday night's game
how personally did you and and your
teammates take it
and todd bowles take it that nobody was
talking about how good this defense was
i mean we didn't take it personally but
it was just crazy to us that we were
still underdogs
we defeated drew brees we defeated aaron
rodgers
and then we was like he was the mvp and
we still was underdogs
man we just knew we had we just wanted
to win a super bowl we didn't really
care about what the media was saying
because the media not out there on the
field
hey so like i said man we don't even
keep score we just running
up and leave you know it's funny that's
uh similar to something that todd bowles
said to peter king
that the guys read everything and they
watch tv and they were
pissed off sorry london that uh i we're
not on london on monday nights but sorry
anyway
that that uh everyone was picking the
chiefs and no one gave them a chance to
win which is just
michael jordan level bullcrap that
it was not you know we've seen the
pregame shows where it's unanimous that
one team's picked across the board and
the other team gets pissed off and wins
there were people out there that thought
the chiefs were gonna win
there were people out there that gave
them a chance but they got themselves
cooked up into a frenzy sharing
that uh that they were going to to be
disrespected and no one believed in them
so anyway to get to the final point
the buccaneers beating brees rogers and
mahomes was what
well first of all mike i guess that
means they don't watch you because you
picked the bucks throughout the whole
entire
season to win this thing so i guess
that's what that's saying
that doesn't help motivate anyone that
doesn't help motivate them
no it doesn't but beating brees back to
the point
beating the quarterbacks they beat brees
aaron rodgers patrick mahomes
i thought was quite a feat when you look
at 55 total points they gave up in those
three games
four touchdowns six interceptions 750
yards it was amazing the defensive
effort they had in those three games
when you start talking about the mvps
and the super bowl mvps and all the
records and everything else that those
three guys have done
it was amazing mike oh and under
appreciated is my word especially in the
nfc championship because look
we will we will praise tom brady where
praise is merited
but also he stunk in the second half of
the nfc championship he threw
interceptions on three straight
possessions
and the buccaneers defense on the last
two stepped up
and held the packers and forced a three
and out
and had sacks on each of the two drives
but for the buccaneers defense
stepping up after those tom brady
interceptions number two and number
three
it would have been the packers and the
chiefs on sunday night and there's a
good chance the chiefs
would have gotten revenge 54 years later
for super bowl number one all right rob
gronkowski's throwback performance last
night was what shireen
nah i thought it was vintage mike and we
talked a lot about
he doesn't look like the same guy he was
even a couple years ago
but he did torch the chiefs twice he was
a big
factor uh against them obviously
yesterday but he had a big game it's his
only hundred yard game in week 12 he had
160
106 yards against the chiefs in week 12.
uh seven touchdowns in the riggers cuz
he was kind of in you know and i guess
he brought leadership to that locker
room but
he didn't make many plays on the field
but i thought he did that in the super
bowl
he made some big plays the box and i
thought he was a difference in the game
mike
he picked a hell of a game to finally
stop creating the impression that he's
running in mud and maybe it was a
a very long con on all of us
that he deliberately slowed down for 18
games and then in game number 19 game
number
20 right 20 games game number 20 is the
one where he
he found the gas pedal and played like
he used to play so uh awesome stuff
from uh from rob gronkowski uh and uh
yeah he
probably will be back for another year
with the tampa bay buccaneers last one
real quick signing leonard fournette was
what
well i thought it was fortuitous mike
because ronald jones was banged up in
the postseason he only had 35 touches
for 139 yards no touchdown in three
postseason games
where fournette really to me looked more
like the fournette that we saw at lsu
he averaged 20.5 touches in the
postseason 112 yards per game and one
touchdown per game he had four total
touchdowns in the postseason
i just thought he was really really good
in the postseason
and it was big that they had him because
of ronald jones
yeah look to me it was typical of the
2020 buccaneers they were going all in
it was gronk it was antonio brown it was
leonard fournette it was guys who were
going to make this team better
we find a way to make it work leonard
fournette got more and more
opportunities as the season unfolded
and it gets back to that point guys like
aaron rodgers guys like russell wilson
looking around saying what are we doing
when these players are available and
they're just sitting there what are we
doing
to improve our chances of getting to a
super bowl
and winning it because what the
buccaneers did and i know there are some
executives around the league that say
it's not sustainable well you know what
it may be
sustainable into 2021 and possibly into
2022.
hi i'm mike tarico and thanks for
watching make sure to hit subscribe for
the latest news and highlights
from nbc sports